after 14 unsuccessful attempts over the  course of last week Kevin McCarthy has  finally been elected Speaker of the  House of Representatives but not before  caving to pretty much all of the  conservative holdouts demands including  a southern Border Protection Plan a  budget that stops an increase in the  debt ceiling an end to all covid  mandates and funding a select committee  to investigate the weaponization of the  FBI and other agencies a term limit vote  a minimum 72-hour reading period before  bills are brought to a vote permission  for single subject bills and increased  voice for the freedom caucus  conservatives on the most important  committees and most consequentially  probably the biggest sticking point for  both McCarthy and the holdouts a return  to the former Congressional Norm of  allowing any member to call a vote to  boot the speaker from his spot